[Music]
this morning on the dish chef with
American roots who's a master of
Mediterranean cuisine born and raised in
Philadelphia Joey campanero was inspired
by the foods of his childhood especially
what came out of his Italian grandmother
and mothers kitchen
after studying restaurant management in
college including a semester in Italy he
worked at top venues around the country
then in 2006 he opened his dream
restaurant little owl in the West
Village neighborhood here in New York it
generated plenty of buzz and with
partner Mike price and paved the way for
two more dining hotspots Market table
and the clam and both in the very same
neighborhood we sat down with him here
last month chef Joey Campanaro good
morning welcome to the dish this may be
my dream dish because you have served up
to one two cocktails popcorn and pie we
are very inspired working together and
come up with a menu we have to make it
fun tell us what else is on this table
so let's start with the ketchup ketchup
pepper popcorn cacio e pepe means cheese
and pepper this next dish is a dish that
I learned how to make for my grandmother
and my mother mmm
so it's cavatelli pasta with kale pesto
and it's topped with fried salami and
Parmesan cheese is really good the next
dish here this is a barbecued ribs
followed by broccolini we have to have
our vegetables right and then this is
one of my favorite salads it's arugula
salad with peaches and strawberries and
figs I heard a rumor that Anthony likes
good ol apple pie you just can't beat it
these two drinks were offering in our
new bar menu at market table the first
is a pineapple punch where we infuse
tequila with grilled pineapple and you
know in our family nothing goes to waste
and so we use the pineapple that was
grilled and infused with tequila
and the barbecue sauce for these ribs
this is really good talk about family
coming from an Italian family I think
we'd all expect you to want to be into
food but when did you get serious about
cooking and knowing that that was a
future there were so many steps along
the way but really it was just
inevitable
I think you were coming from South
Philly everyone is once work in a
restaurant but my first boss was a chef
and so when we had a we had a house down
in Wildwood and Jersey Shore and I saw
this boat that I wanted and it was a
little rowboat and I was 12 years old
and I asked my parents for for his money
to buy this boat and they said mom do
you get a job and so the closest
business was a restaurant it was called
captain max right in North Wildwood New
Jersey what did you do in captain max at
captain max I scrubbed the floor mats
and these huge pots that they used to
make the clam chowder and the turtle
soup in starting at the bottom and that
give you an appetite for being in the
kitchen what it really did wasn't taught
me a work ethic and it taught me the
most important question which is and I
think in life but also in in business is
also is what's next and that that that
question that I had to ask the chef was
what's next chef and that turned into
peeling potatoes or peeling onions
to making sandwiches eventually getting
and being able to put my own chef coat
on so you went from Philly to New York
in New York I made some pretty strong
connections I worked with great people
the one of the most important
connections I made was with my business
partner chef Mike price yes and we work
together at a restaurant on 56th Street
Symphony house waiting salad oh yeah I
was a salad guy and he was and he was in
culinary school that was the beautiful
relationship as they say and next for
you you finally were able also to open
your own place you and Mike together yes
that was a real dream come true and it's
you know it's a story of trust and and
love and risk the restaurant business in
New York City is not easy and it's
ever-changing and you succeed well we we
inspire each other and we aim to remain
relevant by doing what we love and you
know we focus on positivity versus
competition in our relationship and and
we really drive each other as chefs and
as business
and with Market table with one of the
places you have you you think normally a
place after a decade going out of
business or it's just gonna go away
instead you guys have sort of rate
you're redoing things in there we had
this space and we had a perfect
opportunity to create a bar vibe you
know and and when I said that did you
like how dining shifts our restaurants
have never been something as pretentious
but they've always been something about
experience and so in order to have a bar
experience we would really wanted to do
is make a very casually sex sexy
alternative so going out to dinner and
when you walk into a restaurant that's a
bar then it's kind of under promising
and over-deliver but then you know when
you get brought to your table that's
your table for the night and and the
focus is on you and it's in the true
sense of hospitality it's that's what we
wake up and strive to do every day well
we have filled your table today but as
we have you sign the dish let me ask you
if you could fill your table with a few
people other than us share this meal who
would it be with absolutely my mother my
mother and I would hope that she would
say her mother my grandmother and then
her great-grandmother it would you know
I got to spend a lot of time with my
mother this summer Patricia and she's a
huge inspiration chef thank you so much
and for more on chef Joey Campanaro you
can go to our website at CBS this
morning calm